the human wrist the small area of our
bodies has become the latest target in
the race between tech companies but two
clear frontrunners have emerged Fitbit
and Apple oh I miss the Addams Family
anyway yes the battle is heating up
again now that Fitbit the unequivocal
winner in the fitness tracking space is
jumping into smartwatches the new $200
Fitbit blaze is the first Fitbit that
doesn't look like a sporty fitness band
it has a color touchscreen and
customizable bands yep just like that
350 dollar Apple watch Sport sure apples
option has more features but many find
it best for activity tracking
notifications and telling the time so
Apple or Fitbit when it comes to design
it's clear that Fitbit is not yet
well fit for the runway the Apple watch
is far more comfortable and stylish can
you say bezel the black frame
surrounding the Fitbit screen makes it
awkwardly wide here's a fun game I like
to play Fitbit blaze or iPod Nano the
modular design is nice for swapping
bands but the gap between the screen and
the metal enclosure is ugly there's one
place Fitbit rules on hardware unlike
the Apple watch which doesn't last more
than a day the blaze ran three and a
half days because of that it can track
your sleep since Fitbit is primarily
focused on fitness it provides better
activity tracking features but not by
much both devices count steps calories
and heart rate in my tests I found both
to be about even on heart rate readings
and within a couple of beats of a more
accurate chest strap monitor neither has
built-in GPS for tracking a run food
bits app has the edge - it provides a
cleaner interface and you can compete
with your friends the watch also gets
very excited when you hit your goal I
don't win the Powerball or anything
Fitbit also has guided workouts on the
screen but you can do the same with
Apple watch apps 10-minute ABS Apple
watch has 7-minute abs hmm but both
don't do enough with the data it
collects establish a routine and the you
illness fades that's why your deciding
factor will probably be the other stuff
these watches can do if you want deeper
notifications and information on your
wrist go with the Apple watch I love how
the blaze limits notifications to just
calendar texts and calls but I use the
Apple watch quite often to see my daily
schedule check the temperature outside
and quickly respond to a text the police
doesn't have those features okay here's
what I would do if you have an iPhone
and want a smart watch that's good at
fitness tracking get the Apple watch
sport but if you just want a good
fitness tracker that also tells the time
save your money and get the 130 dollar
Fitbit charge HR Fitbit has a ways to go
on providing the SmartWatch essentials
and deeper utility in fitness and health
welcome to the next lap in the race